hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play in words now
this is game that's actually made on the
Source engine which I haven't played a
[ __ ] montt for The Source engine in a
long time um it was released on gamejolt
very recently and from what I saw it was
very extremely well made a high level of
quality from what I could see not in
like the actual graphics of the game but
just in in how it was made in the design
of it so I mean it's obviously made on
the search engine so it's got a pretty
powerful thing for it but powerful
engine body but a Bennigan's unity and
unreal engines aren't exactly wimpy so
but I mean I'm not saying expect the
greatest graphics ever in the world
that's not what I'm saying what I'm
saying is take this game with a grain of
salt and let's see what it's gonna
happen let's have some fun ooh nice fire
effects I can see their budget was there
you know okay so I'm entering a haunted
house which is a pretty typical cliche
in terms of games and guessing why I'm
entering this on dowse is beyond me I
don't have a flashlight nice too many
things that is the old familiars
half-life sound there's the old familiar
is that night all that is left of you
are you trapped on that dark road
because there isn't an exit er because
you can't find one I sometimes wonder
whether you remember the sound of my
voice or it's just another noise in the
background I will try again I will try
one last time do you still remember her
story whose story whose dog whoa um okay
then that doesn't seem good what about
the other rooms in this house
oh well alright then it's just a bed
and the cabinet is this my house or is
this someone else's house and who is she
that I need to remember so many
questions so few answers
it's funny because when I see things
like this I think prop hunt need to turn
into that bathtub but no must not do
that
prop on turn into that limb well okay
then
abnormally loud ladder you have a nice
day
oh there's water here this doesn't make
any sense why is there water here of all
places
on a wooden floor never mind
oh this is nice hello oh look at their
little physically interactable objects
isn't that lovely
okay so um yeah hello excuse me pardon
me
hack it out of the way I said oh I may
need you I'm gonna take you with me cuz
you're actually late you are actually a
light source flunk sank hope no monsters
find me a boom bang boom whoops my bad
sorry did you not wait but okay I don't
know what was going on there but this is
apparently my only source of light so
I'm gonna cherish it take you with me
and protect the theater
hello well well well this doesn't look
pleasant a long hallway wander if
someone try pushing you targeted me and
my birthing a baby got pushing fashion
oh hello you get this blood on the floor
okay node graph out-of-date rebuilding
what
oh good I woke up in a dirty stinky
hospital surrounded by more dirty stinky
rooms another trope of horror games
which is hospitals but
how lady are you doing you gonna come to
kill me
what's going on here some don't feel
right
some feels wrong okay door is locked I
gotta go this one flapping in the wind
the wind of inside this hospital oh oh
don't turn back on oh my god oh come on
Cody back on line listen Oh would you
turn why did you turn it off okay this
is much moodier anyway so I guess that's
all that really mattered okay why is it
so quiet what is going on that's what I
always ask in these horror games was
going on but I don't know why I do
because I never get a definitive answer
very rarely to these horror games
especially the indie ones tell me
exactly why I am do what I do and what
is this some misty
oh so this game was made in Britain land
a I have whom to batteries what does
that mean did I turn on the radiation
screening do I need to turn it off now
will this kill me ow didn't even hurt
okay
oh good long blinking hallway I'm gonna
I'm gonna dumb gonna you know I'm
getting you know okay alright okay so
far so good
oh my blessin is that the way out my
flashlight is now dead what does that
even mean a girl wandered through the
dreary spring rains on a starless
moonless night a doll pendant held
tightly in her hand the water ran from
her cloak and into the marshy grass
counting her footsteps one at a time she
could swear that every so often she'd
hear a step out of time and a sound
coming from the distance Vivian knew
that she had to keep moving onwards
towards the north where's she find her
home on the other side of the river the
and tugged gently in the way he was
headed casting a faint blue glow upon
the horizon okay well what does that
meant or what does that mean what does
that mean it was a flashlight wait
that's the compliant look Wow look like
a blind what blind myself what is that
what is that what is that what is that
who are you look the web it's gonna get
me what are you gonna do huh
Hey whoa what the I guess I got away
from it whatever it was
oh I see I just went into a portal of
demonic hell that's good that's good
one thing that I'm I would like to point
out for this game it really could do
with some ambience ground floor master
key found that's good oh baby don't be
so creepy are you gonna be creepy you're
slightly disturbing wanna go now we're
not follow me very now follow me you
burn up all of me okay
lo Z's okay close them
hey wait a minute no this is the hallway
that I was on ah wait a minute that was
it
oh wait no that's right yeah this is
where I came from originally they need
you
oh loading good this accident was quite
a large download by the way it was about
a gig to download this entire game
actually no the downloaded four hundred
Meg's but when it came out extracted it
was a gig oh wow I found a lot of
batteries for my flashlight don't know
why any of them anybody I think it might
have the afraid of monsters mechanic
style of last night where um you only
have a limited amount of battery but you
can recharge
very slowly if you turn it off and
you're out so that you're never
completely out all the waiting pretty
monsters I'm thinking of a different
game why are the lights turning out is
that thing gonna appear by me I think
John bear by minute or in front of me or
on or somewhere oh look another blue
portal I keep expecting I keep the
expecting that thing to be there it will
be enemies could always use more berries
Oh God
I'm outside now why why why uh what Oh
just pushed it okay it was a push
building okay nestled in the hollow
stump of an oak that sat in the shadow
of a derelict lumber mill Vivian settled
weary from the trek through the darkness
through a gap in the rotting wood she
saw a glimmer of light appear followed
by another and many more the clouds had
finally parted in the star shone more
brightly than they had ever before so
far away it's so full of life her father
had once told her that stars were like a
photo like a lot like photographs
reminders of dissin things to be
cherished
she wanted to herself why her gift
wanted to be taken from her I don't know
that thing around here I'm very
concerned about the status of whatever
the hell that thing is and why it was
following me
hi I see you are you Vivian you Vivian
over there is that you villian the
little bittle of over is that you've
available baby oh boy another portal
into another dimension I can't escape
this one how good I can happens if I
just don't go in it oh I can't progress
uh what does that mean okay you're all
right I guess I'll go outside again the
warm rays that it's shone down through
the trees and dim once again welcoming
an invisible course of churching
chirping as the evening set in I am
having so much trouble reading today the
Knights began to grow warmer in the
force occasionally a branch would snap
somewhere in the distance and the leaves
would shift and shovel it was still out
there but Vivian knew wild that while
she was surrounded by
tripping friends she would be safe even
if she could not see them they'd keep
her safe from it occasionally she would
find a shell attached to the trunk of a
tree another reminder like the every
starry sky in every dusty photograph as
the night she at the night set in she
hidden an abandoned den below the earth
that seemed to be another thing left
behind by a weary soul yeah I don't know
I apologize I'm having in sincere
trouble ah excuse me
who brought some glass yeah I'm having a
lot of trouble reading dad I don't know
why my speaking skills are just not up
to par oh the pendant a bear left her
pocket in some weeks or maybe months
beginning to forget who she was seemed
to bring more Hope than holding on to
the truth the leave began to turn to
brown and orange falling from the trees
they were once part of Viviane extended
a hand and touched the rough bark of the
maple tree stood tall and strong drawn
upwards by the delicate leaves that came
and when he wondered if one day she
would use her gift to show the people
who taken her away for that every life
was just as important she produced the
pendant from him pokken followed its
gentle pull onwards through the leafy
wood leaves crackled distantly in the
pattern of footsteps um it was always
there watching her whenever she
remembered that she carried a gift of
giving life followed closely by the
weight of it brought by the weight it
brought one day beyond the river the
weight will be lifted when she finds her
way home and when I can stop messing up
okay anyway so what about that what did
I do
the gate break release what is that what
is that what did that do something about
this who do I need to go back I've a
feeling I may need to go back what the
hell what wait a minute no no no no no
no no no no something happened something
happened that wasn't supposed to happen
oh no did I break the game did I pull
this lover before I was supposed to pull
it oh no oh no I done goofed
Oh God what have we done Luffy done have
I broken it ever feeling I'm supposed to
be in there somehow oh no way to avoid
oh I know what I do
ah I need to overload it
yeah yeah okay okay I got it I got it I
got it I got this yeah goes all right
what did I do
what did that do what is it did that do
something yeah all right all right all
what what what oh okay there was just an
invisible wall there huh I thought I had
broken the game very sincerely I thought
I did
oh come on wait what
I get really is with his own sound in
this game like I said just a little bit
of excuse me pardon what was that
you say something to me what does fused
collected okay um
damn it I got no flashlights it's all
blinky blinky what's that Oh startled me
no was that Oh a few years collected
well why did I drop it or is that a new
one I'm not sure I think I'm what is
what is up with this what is up with
that
let's messed up man that was going on
here
that's messed up man what the hell some
things in this game seem to be quite off
their rockers uh there's another music
just got another fuse what does it mean
I go in that no not yet okay fuse we
know how do I put the fuse in wait to
the fuses automatically going or what do
I just need to find the last one I don't
know I don't know I think I may need to
find one more before I'm able to go into
that portal do daddy don't know why I'd
want to but that's just the way it be
little easier to find him when it was in
the darkness
all right Oh Oh wrong with you
oh we're wrong with you Oh what's wrong
with your head what are you oh it's
doing oh I did wrap your eyeballs where
are you gonna hide in the darkness you
know in the burger
oh stop looking at me Dublin yeah me
that's right go off on your own
I don't know what you're doing no no
what's wrong with you oh you're so weird
oh just let me go on my own business
flock over there
oh so weird
run oh oh oh no yes okay so I can't go
here until I get the last fuse but I
don't know the last views is or the
light views they get all the fuses oh I
need more batteries I wasted my
batteries because I didn't realize that
my light was on while I was reading
those notes
oh who the hell those eyes miss there's
got to be a place that I haven't gone
yet in this psycho bonkers crazy area
hey baby mover this way I swear there's
got to be a place that I haven't gone
yet
oh you still we're oh oh oh no - dare
don't you dare don't you dare go near
that done what is with this everything's
broken and weird those those strange I
can't find the last views I don't know
what the dough oh oh ah oh come on you
gotta be joking he was right behind me
the entire time
ah fudge Jesus get the dog oh oh
kill me I don't know where to go ah come
on okay well this is easy that made it
easy to respawn haha didn't quite expect
that you dig that's all you spawn
I saw you spawn I'm getting out here I'm
getting out here okay ha ha
how's weird Oh
oh no the old elevator falling down trow
oh no I'm gonna die except not cuz I can
climb up out of the bottom of it or top
of it or bottom top or whatever all
right once again I still don't know how
I went from going into a house into a
hospital don't know what all the portals
are about that's not good
ah Vivian darling Vivian can you throw
like a rope or something give me a rope
or something oh ah
Vivian Oh
okay - oh look I'm in a swamp of some
sort so ah I don't have a flashlight
anymore either that's quite interesting
oh no no no I was gonna read that oh
damn it okay sorry guys
I meant to read that but it didn't let
me apparently okay into the blue light
okie dokie where am I now
what new nightmare see now they have
some ambience with the music there with
a little the low tones just anything to
make it a bit more interesting whoa
something happened here I'm guessing I'm
not supposed to stay in this house wait
what sorry
run door over here Vivian I'm coming
baby whoa
okay this clean yeah I'm gonna get in
this boat haha alright Emma oh now
there's a note there ah
vivianne darling oh my baby
what my ragtime gal
can I get off the boat now can i I have
to stay on the bone oh she's gone
where'd she go my love have disappeared
no I'm just gonna assume that Vivian
because that would make the most sense
here we're just gonna stay on my little
boat ride I know I stopped okay
up and off the boat uh can I get off the
boat
thank you there we go back into the
hospital I guess which is probably for
the best maybe haha on flashlight ah
dead body in they've told me that I have
no choice and I'm to decide what happens
to you but how is that fair it isn't
fair because nothing is fair even when
the girl found a way home how would she
know that her father would even still be
there how do I know you're still here I
don't know what to do anymore
okay if you say so maybe you should just
let me go home as you know it is
entirely your decision what what does
that mean what is entirely but but do
consider his happiness as well I am sure
he loves you very much
I cannot do it why does it have to be me
is this is not my fault I tried didn't I
didn't I try hard enough I am such an
idiot
don't be so hard because I know you are
still here oh I thought it was a person
please help me
Am I am I supposed to believe Lieber do
they do I see a blue light oh okay then
okay then
all right into the blue light yeah I
didn't really have much of a choice
there maybe I could have walked away
from the switch I don't know maybe that
was symbolic of pulling the plug on
someone I don't know a girl wandered
through the dreary spring rains on a
starless Moony moonlit night oh that was
the end wait a minute huh oh hang on
there was a lot of symbolism and
something in there hang out I'm trying
to piece these guys give me a second um
Vivian was a girl trying
there was distort what the story was all
about Vivian was trying to travel
through some dreary woods on a starlit
moonless night where she was trying to
make her way to someone and there was
some reference to her father of some
sort who she didn't even know would
still be there maybe she was trying to
go to the hospital that's why they was
so much set in the hospital with medical
equipment and maybe um man was in a coma
and she had to pull the plug I don't
know I don't know what happened that's
that's the best guest that I can piece
together it wasn't like I missed two
notes there I feel bad about it maybe
you guys could have paused on one but I
missed the other completely but I don't
think there would have been like that
crucial to tell me exactly what was
going on probably it was but I missed it
anyway sincerely apologize for that I
usually don't miss those notes and I
always try to read them but a dad so if
you guys have any idea you want plays by
yourself trying to piece together maybe
something else is there that I missed
you guys can let me know in the comments
below so thank you all so much for
watching click the annotation for more
videos that I've done and as always
we'll see
in next video
hi
Wow I'm the best ever